says that the thing he will most likely
be remembered for
the sun monster
climate is not nonsense dealing with
climate change is one of the biggest
things that people like me and people
like him will be remembered for after
we're gone
that is not true I was trying to think
well maybe that's true in the sense that
uh Pete budaje just spending all of his
time worried about the sun monster he's
not spending any of his time worried
about the railroads and the bridges and
the roads so that's why that's what
he'll be remembered for no I actually
believe Pete Buda judge will be one of
the only Transportation secretaries in
history to be remembered at all very few
people can name even One Transportation
secretary in history I remember Elaine
Chao had it during Trump's
Administration I I couldn't name you a
transportation secretary earlier than
that but I think people will remember
Pete butterjudge because his tenure has
been so catastrophic